so
the title of my talk is programming
language tourism
and uh
i'm gonna start off kind of slow and uh
you'll see eventually where i'm going
but for now just sort of bear with me
um and will my pointer bear with me
so i was born in moscow
i'm in moscow
i'm five years old
and
it's dark
outside
it's winter
and it's very very cold
i'm shivering
i'm tapping my feet
to keep myself warm
and i'm doing that because i'm
with my older brother
he's two years older than me misha's
here
and uh we're
we're waiting
we're waiting and it's cold
and it's been hours
and eventually
mom comes to pick us up
we get home
and even though i was bundled up
and my brother made sure i had my hat on
me
he missed the spot
my left ear
was exposed
and it was the size of a fist
it was really cold for the next 15 years
of my life whenever i was embarrassed
nervous
or if it was cold the ear would swell up
again
okay
if we start thinking about programming
languages as places
we can have analogies that allow us to
assess how we're doing in a place
how we feel about a place
and so if i was
young the way that we were young when we
were programmers
and i was thinking about how cold it was
without realizing that my ear was being
hurt at the time
what happens is that all of us can
experience these things
and it can be
a traceback error
it can be
an indentation error
you don't know that it hit you but it
stops you in your tracks when you're a
newbie
and your brother is only two years older
than you
he doesn't really necessarily know
better
okay so that is what i'm gonna talk
about today that is as serious as it's
going to get so that was the most
uncomfortable it'll be so
here we go
about me
i am
a senior software developer at bloomberg
i am on the jupiter steering council i
am a core matplotlib developer and my
contact information is on there and i'll
repeat it again at the end
um i'm actually uh
supposed to be working on matplotlib
release 3 2.0
3.2.0 don't tell tom caswell that i'm
here okay it's just between you and me
like by the time this goes up on youtube
it'll be done but it's not done yet
so where are we
we're in pycon taiwan
specifically in room zero of the
humanities and social sciences building
and that's how i know i'm at a python
conference because the indexing starts
at zero
that usually gets a bigger laugh
but
thank you yeah yeah good no you don't
have to clap no but just just a bigger
leg
it's good
like i mentioned this is my first time
in taipei and so
a question that we can ask each other
right when somebody says oh i'm visiting
here where are you coming from
and there are different scales to
answering that
being a jupiter person i might answer oh
planet earth
but then you start to zoom in the united
states california san francisco or the
bay area as though there's only one bay
area
the east bay specifically is where i
live and then you might get into the
cities of whether it's oakland or
berkeley
and then within that right you can also
say which part are you on the south side
are you
in downtown where are you
and so
i've lived in 17 different places that i
can count on
in just two countries so most of that
was in the united states just two places
in in russia
and we will now go through each one of
them
in excruciating detail
no i'm not gonna do that
occupational identity
very common question when you meet
somebody is what kind of work do you do
and again depending on who's asking you
that question
your answer might be well it's computers
it's all you need to know
and you know if you're feeling more
generous or
the time allows for it well i program
i'm a programmer
i do python programming
and when you're here at pycon taiwan you
might say well i do scientific python
and if you're really getting into it if
they got excited about that well i do
maplot lib or jupiter or numpy right
all these things and again
you can say which part of that code base
do you concentrate on because jupiter is
a big project maple outlet is a big
project numpy's a big project
so programmer identity a lot of us
will say that i am a python
[Music]
programmer let's dig into that what that
means because the title of my talk is
you know the subtitle is leave python
and see the world so why are we doing
that
so stack overflow trends so not a
perfect measure not everyone goes on
stack overflow but a lot of people do
and so let's look at the activity there
so
here's what it looks like over the years
in the last 10 years python has become
the top tagged type of question on stack
overflow okay so if i gave the stock a
year ago that wouldn't have been true
javascript was still ahead but now it's
python
yeah that's something to be excited
about absolutely
the
stack overflow developer survey from
last year it comes out around november
so this year's hasn't been released yet
but uh
in answering the question of what is
the most wanted language that people
want to learn
it's python so this is for a language
that you don't already use in your work
and you don't already know what's the
next language that you would like to
learn
vast majority a quarter of the
respondents would pick python over any
other language to to learn next
so there's a lot of us
and there's more coming right
and then the final piece from the stack
overflow data is what is the most loved
programming language
so this means that i'm programming in
this language and i don't see myself
switching to another language i'd rather
work in that particular language so rust
is number one they're fanatics kotlin's
number two and python is number three
not too far behind so there's
lots of people that are programming
python today
they're happy and there's more of us
coming right so
let's take slightly different tack can
we double check our data is that really
happening
so let's look at github so more open
source things right not every not all
development is open source but it will
give us some insights about it
so the top programming language by
repositories created
was javascript
second is java and third is python
so again there's a lot of python and
open source big surprise there
i bet you didn't know that right
and here's a chart over the years
for
contributors so the top number of
contributors for
a python project for a project is
javascript there's lots of those on
github java again and python has been at
the number three spot since 2015.
okay but we can break that down
by region
and you can see that in some places that
orange line
it's in the number two spot in north
america and oceania
okay
so even though python is number three
overall in some places it is
it takes the
number two spot
and again growth by contributor so this
is year over year how many how fast is
it growing python even though it's
already one of the big ones
continues to grow fast you'll notice
javascript's not on that list but what
is is typescript right so a lot of
people that know javascript are shifting
away to typescript okay
um
and then that's interesting go made this
list and go made a previous list as well
so we'll get back to go in a little bit
but python again seems to be a great
language to be in
so why would you leave python and some
of you are new and i'm hoping that peop
you can point other people new people
that are trying to get started in
programming to the stock or to this idea
of thinking about programming languages
as places
um to help them understand that that
first choice it matters but it doesn't
matter a whole lot
because you can't go wrong with learning
python that's what i'm trying to
summarize here so i'm not knocking
python python is great and if you just
got here perfect
great
but occasionally especially if you're
using python for work you might want to
go on a programming vacation
right you might want to again thinking
about programming
languages as places
you might want to go somewhere else
i work in california
sometimes i go on vacations in
california but sometimes i like to go
somewhere else sometimes i get to go
somewhere else for work
okay my frozen ear
already alluded to this but it was an
indentation error
with an indentation error in code that a
lab made and i shared
and his text editor
did not
give
any indication it did not give the
ability to switch between tabs and
spaces and so he inserted a bunch of
tabs and in my editor i had not yet set
it up to highlight tabs in red and being
like no
and so i was looking at the code and
what what indentation level here this
this looks fine right
and
that's actually a picture from around
the time that my
uh ear was frozen so i'm on the right
my brother misha is on the left and this
was the venue that we were going to we
were learning how to dance
and we were waiting for my mom because
class had been canceled and she
instructed she knew it was going to be a
blizzard she knew it was going to be
cold and she instructed us to stay
inside but we were kids and we didn't
listen to that instruction and we were
out there way longer than we should have
been
so i look pretty pleased right
um after seeing kirchhoff's talk
yesterday i would also think that uh the
unicode decoder is a similar kind of
problem right it's a frozen year for
someone else especially during the
python 2 python 3 transition would have
been like what what's going on
so another point that i want to make is
that places change
so the walrus operator which was talked
about yesterday is coming in python38
will have positional only arguments
actually some of my colleagues at
bloomberg were helping in the london
office helped implement that
um for positional only arguments and
functions and then f strings will have
the self-documenting expressions on
there
so it's also the case that we change
right so it's not just the places
changed we changed those the things that
i wanted and enjoyed out of python
12 years ago when i started are
different than what i enjoy about it
today
and what i seek in a language in a place
that i'm in right when you're younger
people like to be somewhere where
there's a large you know nightlife and
things like that as you get older you
like things maybe kind of quieter
somewhere where you can just not be
disturbed while you're having your
morning coffee things like that
so ian bicking has a great post about
saying goodbye to python
and as a reminder and it's been
mentioned in several talks that python27
will stop being supported january 1st
2020.
okay
so
never
i never want to say i never got to say
goodbye to python
especially python 2 right so i'm going
to say goodbye to python 2
in my own way
so i like to write poems and sometimes
they just strike me as
a good way to express yourself and i
just let words flow out of me
and write them down on paper without
thinking too hard about it in this case
i've you know typed it up in the last
couple of days so this isn't going to be
great right this isn't you know
shakespearean level things but it's
something right it's something
so i hope you'll indulge me here
from dunder past
import nostalgia
goodbye old friend dear python2
a dozen years since i met you
it seems like only yesterday print was a
statement
range returned a list
and x range was a thing
no stars or slashes in my death
life was simpler
unicode was
uh
fun
async await were waiting in the wings
thanks for the memories
you were great
and in memoriam
after you're gone in 2020
i'll still fondly wear a shirt that says
to eat
so programmer identity getting back to
this idea
i am a python programmer
well python is just an adjective here
it's replaceable with a geographic
marker
so you could say i'm a taiwanese
programmer
right
and for many of you that's true
but at the end
i'm a programmer is
a more definitive statement about who we
are in terms of programmer identity
right
so
when you want to leave python whether
it's for vacation or
you know at some point maybe for good
there maybe there will be greener
pastures for us to move on to
uh how will you know you're ready
now you didn't know there was going to
be a quiz from yesterday's keynote how
many were here for yesterday's keynote
raise your hands
all right
all right
so you'll remember that
professor lin talked about the
hyperbolic tangent 10h so that's here in
red or reddish color
right
and so
most learning is like that you start off
at zero
then you ramp up
and at some point you start to taper off
right there's only so much to know about
python
so as you get to the end it's sort of
you're learning at a slower rate
and you're also it's taking you less
effort right so the i'm here plotting
the first and the second derivatives
um
this was plotted using matplotlib i love
plotting again and sometimes i don't get
to plot for a while because i don't deal
with data the way i used it in grad
school anymore so this was great i was
like yes i remember this let's remove
the axes let's make it pretty let's put
in some styling in there it was great
so the first derivatives is shows you
how much effort it is right so that's
that sort of bell-like uh curve and so
as we get to the middle that is the most
effort that it's going to be to learn
things right
and then the second derivative is
showing us the change in effort right so
the change in that effort
is again it goes to zero and then it
starts to be easier it gets easier and
easier as you get to the bottom right
because you're not learning at the same
at the same steep slope
so
i would say that
zero in this case serves as the middle
point right and that is a good time to
start thinking about a vacation
now you might say how do i know i've
gotten to halfway through learning
python as a new programmer or learning
any language
and i think the amount of effort that it
takes you should be an indicator right
so if i'm finding myself oh yeah this is
i know what i'm doing i'm sort of
cruising along you're well past that
halfway point and you're ready to keep
going
and you're perhaps you're
you're deserving vacation you've been
working hard right depending on how long
it took you to get there
and you will get there it's just i
fundamentally believe anyone can program
and everyone should program
not everyone has to do it for a living
but i think everyone should be able to
just like a basic literacy thing you
should be able to write and you should
be able to write programs they don't
have to be great programs but everyone
can do it
so i
didn't i wasn't going to bore you with
all the places that i've been
in terms of physical places but i do
want to talk a little bit about the
programming languages that i sort of
went through over the years
so it started off with basic like you
could say i was born in basic because
that was the first programs that i wrote
and uh
if you're just getting started in
whatever language
don't be
too bothered if you're feeling like
you're just copy pasting the same things
or you're writing the same program all
over again over and over again
that is what i was a kid
so it was
shortly
after
the ear incident my dad actually bought
a computer
he went to
he was teaching at a university in italy
for two months
and
he was eating just
concentrated chicken broth so you're
taking concentrated chicken broth adding
hot water to save money to
go into the duty-free shop on his way
back home after two months of saving all
that money to be able to buy a computer
our first 286 to bring it home for
for me and my three older brothers to to
play with and for him to be able to do
his work which fundamentally allowed him
to then immigrate to the united states
uh using
you know the skills and the access to
machine that he had by having a machine
at home so i'm very grateful for that
but i didn't even though i started in
basic i wasn't i wasn't a great basic
programmer i didn't really know what i
was doing and so i just kept
writing the same program of you know
what is your name you know you get that
back and then
if name equals paul
you're awesome you know if else
you know
you're terrible go away go clean your
room because it was mostly with my
brothers that i would
talk to or have those were my first
users if you will
my mom probably too
okay and then the first programming
language where things started to click
for me oddly was quake script
how many know quake
so quake is a first person shooter it's
one of the original 3d
shooters
a video game that i played as a kid it
was great and the thing about quake is
that it had this ability to
change what different buttons when you
press different buttons on your keyboard
you could write little programs so you
could change the weapons or you could
change how you walk so one of the things
that i remember seeing and this is when
it started to click is this idea of
um you can press a button to go
to the left right you can press a
different button to go to the right
and then you could turn with your mouse
left and right
and then i wrote
the or
it wasn't it wasn't original i saw
someone else really because that's how
you start to learn the program right is
you copy someone else
i saw someone else had made it so that
as you take a side step you also turn
and you also turn so this circle
scraping out algorithm right the very
basic thing was when it started to click
for me oh i get it and then i started to
write some things to be able to switch
what what weapon my character was
holding in the game and it's like okay i
see what's going on here
and this was around the time um
that linux was starting to become very
popular
and
this is a true story i switched to using
linux
for a very silly reason
i knew that my quake cd was you know had
50 megabytes worth of software on there
the rest were audio track so you could
actually it was neat you could pull out
the cd after the game loaded and put in
a different audio cd and listen to that
while you're playing your video game so
that was cool
but i knew that
you know 50 megabytes of stuff
eventually i copied it to the hard drive
so i could just play the audio cd
whenever i wanted to without having to
plug in the the real cd 50 megabytes of
stuff lived on my computer but i saw
this linux thing and the quake binary
for it was 276
oh my god this is this must be a super
superior operating system you know here
i was on windows what was i thinking
you know wasting 50 megabytes of space
and it turns out it was just the server
it wasn't the client didn't have any of
the rendering it was just pushing the
bytes around
but nevertheless that is my start
and uh when we moved again i mentioned
the 17 places i didn't have a lot of
friends in the new town that i moved in
so i decided to take c plus plus at the
local community college so this was
right after ninth grade
and so the c plus that i learned in 1999
and 2000 is very different from c plus
plus 11 and 2017 so this is again back
to that point the programming languages
change
sometimes for the better sometimes for
the worst you know everyone
is entitled to their own opinions
but that's the way it is
all right
so before we leave python
let's go for a quiet walk
and reflect how we got here i just told
you a lot about how i got here
and i thought you could use just a
moment for yourself so it's not just
about me
to think about
how did you end up like what were the
first programs that you wrote
what is it that happened here
and um
to sort of help facilitate that just so
that we're not
focused on me or anything like that
i've recorded when i started
my current job and i visited new york
back to places i visited new york for
the very first time three years ago and
i walked through central park
and in central park i i have this
recorder which i intended to start
recording this talk but i guess i forgot
i had this recorder on me and i recorded
just walking around central park for
an hour
and uh we're not obviously we're not
going to play the whole hour here
and let me start recording myself now so
i have this for posterity
uh but let's play a little bit of what
it sounds like to walk through central
park and go for a stroll
oh and i should plug in the audio
shouldn't i
pardon me
[Applause]
how's that
i don't know how the sound level is
going to be i'll try to
is it going through
no
um
oh it's on hdmi output okay
it's windows yeah
[Music]
okay get it back to the headphone jack
uh maybe send it back to presets
default
i'm sure okay
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
me
yeah
is
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
right so how was that
good
it's amazing how
having recorded that three years ago
i can still visualize what path
i took for parts of the more salient
points of that audio right so i remember
where the saxophone player was and i can
feel myself being there so this
embodiment that we have as people right
is so powerful right we should really
use this um way of thinking more often
so
um that's one of the things that was
motivated me to to give this very
experimental talk that i'm giving to you
today
all right so before we get going
now that we've said our goodbyes there
are some caveats
okay
there is no substitute for experience
and what i mean by that is the best that
i will be able to tell you
about what some of these programming
languages are like is like a postcard
or a brief summary of my trip to japan
or germany
now i've never been to japan or germany
right so i can't tell you but i can only
learn about it from someone else
and by the way
do you know about pycon japan
seems like a great conference i i'm sure
you haven't heard anything about it but
you should really look into it it's
really good
all right
another caveat is that my idea of fun
isn't necessarily yours
right so we're all different
and
for some people chopping wood is fun
for others it's painting
for others it's painting a fence
it might be a roller coaster
that's really fun
or it might be
mountaineering
right being out there in the wilderness
alone
risking life for no reason other than
you intended to do that
okay for others it might be staying in a
fancy hotel
that's also fun
right so
to each their own
okay so the things that i might
like to about a programming language
won't necessarily be the things that you
like about it
okay i also like this idea of farming
being the original full stack
development
because you kind of get to make all
decisions as a small-time farmer right
right you're situated in a place
and you get to decide what kind of crops
to grow
and you're not completely doing you're
not like writing the operating system
from scratch right like you go out into
town and pick up whatever provisions you
need but you're mostly working on your
own you're making your own decisions
and you're reaping the benefits of those
decisions down the line
right
and then you can think about sort of
modern living where we have careers and
jobs is sort of removed from that right
so we don't get to be full stack
development you don't get to have as
much impact
in any given field because there's so
much for you to worry about right but as
you start to specialize more and more
then you get to zoom in
and really focus because everything
you know everything is
works at multiple scales right
everything is fractal as you zoom in
there's more things to zoom in on and
more things to zoom in on so there's
there will never be a shortage of things
to do or programming languages to learn
or aspects of it to to work with
okay
so with those caveats out of the way
the first programming language i want to
talk about is scratch from mit
raise your hand if you've ever heard of
scratch or a block visual block
programming language
okay so a lot of you have and those of
you who haven't highly recommend it
particularly parents in the room or when
you become a parent and or if your
parent friends say i want to get my kid
into programming how do i do it this is
a great way because scratch eliminates
syntax errors
there's no way for you to stitch things
together with that will have an
indentation error right
what's more is that scratch actually has
a notion of typing so if we look here so
oh
that's the wrong button uh this
doesn't come out on the screen so we'll
just look at the top maybe i'll use this
it's all these blocks that are they're
colored different based on what they do
and then the slots inside some of them
are actually typed
in the sense that this
diamond shape whatever whatever that's
octagon hexagon hexagon this hexagon
yeah it's six yes good this hexagon
shape
will only accept expressions right so it
has to be an expression that goes in
there
uh if it's a value
that's
a circular thing it's like this oval
shape that can go in inside of
expressions like it's this and that
right and so
you you
get the sense of you know the square
blocks won't fit into the the circular
holes so you kind of get a sense of what
goes where and you don't make mistakes
as someone that's just learning how to
program
um and so this is a great way of
thinking about it and this might look a
little familiar
daisuke in his talk yesterday mentioned
make code arcade
and
that's also great so
there's a website so scratches
you run it on the web and there's
actually a community of other
programmers that are working on it many
of them are children that are that are
making drawings making interactive
fiction with it um make code arcade is
also starting to become a platform like
that and the thing i like about makecode
arcade is that it gives you a way in
to transition from just the visual block
into a different language
so in this case up at the top you can
switch right between the block
representation and the javascript
representation
and so here you can make mistakes right
so the guard rails the bumpers if you're
a bowling fan come down right so you're
you don't have as much safety
but you're you get more power that way
right you get to see what's underneath
the hood you can copy pasting is a lot
more reasonable in this way than it is
on the visual side of visual block side
of things
a wish list item because i'm up here and
i get to you know wish things
somebody out there should make this for
python
or tell me
that it's already exist and i just
haven't found it right so to be able to
go from the visual block representation
to python representation right that's a
that's a reasonable thing we have the
ast module you can parse some code
figure things out i think that'd be
great i think that'd be a boon for
giving people the ability to reason
about their programs in a different way
and visualize them
okay
and so
confession time
i do not have
a smartphone
have one of these
and uh so even if i went to golang as a
country i wouldn't take photos there so
i wouldn't have photos to show you
okay so i'm just gonna talk about
go
and how it makes me feel
and cover some of the points here
so
it's true that i
write go code without using syntax
highlighting
and the reason i do that is it slows my
brain down
i'm forced to think more about what each
character means
and what it represents
okay
and after a while it just becomes this
quieter thing right it's the central
park feeling as opposed to being on the
street streets of manhattan there's not
a lot of noise coming at you flashing
red and green and you got a syntax error
and it flashes and there's a thing that
pops up and tries to auto correct for
you none of that is happening in my
editor i just turn off syntax
highlighting and i do deal with the
errors as they come but it's just just a
slightly different it's a slower pace
right
um the tooling is very important and so
one amazing feature of golang is have
you ever written a small python program
that
then you wanted to share with a friend
maybe a non-technical friend
ideally you just want to give them
binary right if you knew what operating
system they're on you just here have
this thing run it do it yeah good luck
python
if it's pure python okay there are there
are ways you can do pi2 exe or similar
things on a mac but uh if it's pulling
in
pandas or numpy or matplotlib
uh so what you're gonna do is you're
gonna um hang on you're gonna you're
gonna go to anaconda no wait no you're
gonna go to pip no python.org and it's a
mess right it's a mess for somebody
non-technical to get into our world and
we should be more welcoming right we
don't need to bring them in to have them
programming with the first time we can
give them the benefit of our programs
and go programmers have it made so the
go uh language was bootstrapped from the
plan 9 operating system which was
written at at t bell labs which was
involved a lot of the original unix
developers
and the original developers of c so the
go compiler is bootstraps from the c
compiler on
from plan nine
and you only have to take change two
environment variables
in any
platform that supports the go
programming language in order to create
binaries for all the platforms that
support
the go
programming language
so if i'm on this windows machine and i
change that go os to linux or mac os
i think they call it darwin but
regardless and i iterate i make a little
for loop and iterate over a bunch of
different arc architectures i will have
that many binaries made and just you
know
go build and i'll have it and i'll be
able to grab
a binary a real binary that doesn't link
against lib c or anything like that it's
just makes system calls at the kernel
level right so it's completely portable
and you know a a small program will will
be fairly small it might be something
like two megabytes or something like
that a binary that you can hand somebody
that will do real work for them that
they didn't have to install anything
okay that's something to think about
something we can learn from a different
programming language
another wonderful thing about go format
is
yesterday uh when dustin asked you know
how many know a pep number everyone said
pepe right well go format gofund as they
call it just enforces it at the language
level so every syntactical
sort of
whether or not we use tabs or spaces
they use tabs
it's okay
um
whether how many you know how many do we
indent before or after
you know the for loop curly brace thing
all those decisions you
you don't have to worry about
moreover go fix allows you as the
language progresses and goes from go 10
to go 1.11 go 1.17 whatever it is
there's a go fix program that will
fix any syntax changes in the language
itself between versions
so it's it's like python two to three
except it's actually very very useful
and it works and it's used in production
all the time to upgrade real code bases
right so another thing we could you know
learn from a different programming
language
uh
interesting
go development is that the errors are
returned so whenever you have a function
that might err it returns the value that
was being computed and
an error placeholder so either that
error is nil or nothing basically right
or it is a real error so whenever you're
calling a function that returns these
two things the next thing you're always
doing is checking whether or not that
error was
a real error or not
and so you're always
forced as a user to make decisions about
errors that might happen
you don't have to know that oh i'm going
to call this function but it might raise
this error so let me do a try catch
except around it right you don't have to
do that it's just in the function it
will one of the things that it returns
if it can error is an error right so
that's an interesting pattern
so the user gets to deal with it all the
time another interesting thing that they
have is this idea of you know you defer
something so something's going to happen
and in this context i want to make sure
at the beginning that i dispose of
something by the time i'm done falling
through this function but you can write
it anywhere in the body so you can write
it right up at the top oh i just use
this thing i want to make sure to call
these other things once i'm out of this
context right and so you just defer that
and then
it'll it'll happen for you you don't
have to worry about doing something at
the very end okay
it does have an elegant robust
concurrency model and that was sort of
like the touristy thing that people were
excited about go when it first came out
is like oh i get to use go routines and
channels and be using all these cores
it's going to be super cool
in practice i even though it was neat
and i did find myself reaching for the
shiny new toy when i started go
programming i don't use it all that much
it is useful um
with channels you have this idea of
typed pipes so you could pipe values
over back and forth except their values
of a guaranteed type so again static
typing helps um sort of make
make your programs a little bit
a little bit more robust
and then interfaces provide safer duct
typing so you define an interface and go
and any which was a set of methods
that you think an object should have and
any object regardless of what other
things it does if it has those objects
with that kind of signature you'll be
able to use it as that interface type
okay so
go i find is a programming language that
is optimized for teams
you can't get too clever with it
you do end up writing for loops in it to
iterate over things and so it's sort of
it looks like it's low level code but
it's very clean and with all the tooling
and the lack of cleverness you don't
have stack decorators with meta classes
and things like that you can't tangle
yourself up too much right as an excited
programmer likes to do
uh you know when you learn a new thing
you want to use it and
the the new things that you have to use
in in go it's pretty much just go
routines and channels once you get that
out of your system
you're okay you're just programming
right with python we do have some depth
and people get excited about i'm going
to make a class that's going to generate
another class and wait i'm not done
it'll do another thing and they'll have
this callback registry right we can we
can create all sorts of things and and
go sort of as a language
optimizes for the whole team not just
the cleverest people on the team but
everyone
oh i have my clicker all right
experiences in elm elm is a front-end
language it's a functional language that
compiles a javascript and it's used just
to make interfaces
okay
and if this works
okay elm has a clean architecture you
have three things in an elm program
a model
which is
state
the
things that can change in your program
you have an update function that takes a
model and a command
and returns a new model
okay so that's you know that's how you
change that state and then you have a
rendering function which takes a model
and puts it on the screen including
into that user interface including any
command triggers that you know on mouse
down do this on input change do that
okay if this sounds familiar this is
exactly what reactant redux
has
and uh it's in the elm world it's called
the elm architecture and that's where
that's where it comes from
what elm allows you to do is eliminate
runtime errors
so you get a lot more compile time
errors in elm
and again this is postcard view you kind
of have to believe me or look into it
yourself but
when you
take the command for example right i
said an update function takes a model
and a command well command can be one of
you know five different things
right and suppose i added a sixth type
of command to my code
somewhere in that update function
there's a case statement switch right
for you know if command does this do
that command is one of the five things
that were there originally
do something about it right
and the elm compiler will
tell me hey buddy
how's it going
all right yeah you added this new thing
here the sixth command type and you
didn't take care of it in the following
places in this case statement in this
case statement and there
so could you take care of that and
we'll be good
so it's amazing how good the error
messages are in elm
it's just fantastic
um
compiles to javascript but it does allow
it to interrupt with javascript so you
have a way you there's a support system
of speaking to the javascript world
because you are running it in the
browser after all
but
but it's
done in the elm way and so
with
code that calls out to javascript those
are considered to be impure
and uh you can't publish to the elm
repository any code that does that so no
library code coasted called the
javascript which again pushes the
responsibility to you the individual
user of this less safe way of
interacting with your with your
javascript runtime so if you want to do
it you're welcome to do it but we're not
going to allow you to make a mess for
other people
that are going to have to clean up
and at the language level
the semantic versioning is enforced by
the language tools so it's a language
where you annotate all your types so you
know what everything is
right
and
we won't let you
we the the elm compiler
won't let you publish things that keep
the same version if any of the apis have
changed because it keeps track of all
the apis
right so if you change the
if you change it type slightly somewhere
else
you know in one little thing you added a
new parameter it would be like nope
sorry you got to bump the version
right so it again it
makes it easier for you not to hold a
foot gun right a gun that's pointed at
your foot or the only thing you can do
is pull the trigger and hurt yourself
right
it doesn't have doesn't happen so that's
that's an amazing refreshing thing that
i found about elm
all right
last language that i want to talk about
is idris
so idris is
you probably have never heard of it has
anyone heard of idris
don't see anyone yeah okay good
something new
look it up it's great idris looks a lot
like haskell
but it's it's simpler as a language in
terms of its syntax
and it's deeper as a language in terms
of the kinds of programs that you write
the uh it is the most academic of the
languages even though idris is out to i
think 1.3 or something right now and
idris two is being worked on uh there's
not a huge community of interest
programmers out there
much less than elm
let alone golang right golang is a major
mainstream language idris is this
academic language right now but what
idris does have is this notion of
dependent types that are very elegantly
written in idris
and what dependent types do
is they allow you to not only say oh my
program takes a string and returns uh
and a number say and returns a list
of strings right so that might be like
repeat a string multiple times and
return a list
in idris you can say you can specify
that return type as that i'm going to
take
a string
and a number n and return a list of
length n
of strings
okay so you have
this expression of
the size of the type that is part of the
type
okay so that's it's kind of weird but it
allows you to write much
tighter programs
in that now if you have
a list concatenation function
right and in idris these
length lists that have a length to them
they're called vectors so if you have a
vector
of length n
and you want to add it to a vector of
length m
the resulting vector should be of length
n plus n right
and so if it if your program doesn't do
that at the type level you didn't do
your job right so it just won't compile
okay
and it's might be difficult to
reason about this but bear with me and
this is like sort of as academic as
it'll get
suppose we had a function that removes
an element from a list of length n
okay so you you take a list of length n
and you take an element
what should it return
should return a list of length n minus 1
right that kind of makes sense
except for one thing
how do you know that element was in the
list
you didn't
right you didn't know you didn't know
and you don't know ahead of time whether
or not an element will you know any
given element that could be passed to
you will be in that list so you can't
guarantee that the return value
will be a length of length n minus one
so how do you get around this
well you get around this with proofs
you provide a guarantee that that
element will be there
so at some point earlier in the program
before you try to call this function
you have a check for whether or not this
element is indeed in that list of length
n
and if it is
you your function
now
also takes the proof of the argument and
accepts it it's a if it's a valid proof
then it's fine for you to return list
list of length n minus one
if it's not
if you do a check if that element is in
the list and it wasn't in the list then
you are forced as a programmer to decide
what to do in that case because you're
not going to be allowed to call that
function that returns n minus 1 elements
anymore right because you don't have
proof that that element is in there in
fact you have proof that it's not in
there
right so you can guarantee that the
thing that will be
uh
yeah the thing will not be in there so
you can't call i'm sort of repeating
myself here i hope that wasn't too
difficult but i hope i've sort of like
issued an interesting part of your brain
that goes huh
i didn't know programming with types
could be sort of this
the safe and this
fun the other thing that um is fun about
idris is
the auto generation of code so a lot of
the code that
and it's similar to to the the elm world
so suppose we had some command type that
could be that was a union type of of you
know five different things
in idris
with integrate
it allows you to integrate with your
text editor where you can say oh can you
do me a case statement for all the
things that that command can be and it
will come back to you you know filling
all those five different possibilities
out with stubs for what and they're
called holes in idris with what should
go in their next sort of a placeholder
like now you decide what the next steps
to do
and so it's this
because of the richness of the type
system
the
writing of code becomes much more of a
dialogue
the
linter and the compiler isn't
babysitting you saying you missed this
you missed that you missed that you're
asking it like what should go here okay
what you go here yeah yeah that that
sounds good once you go here and then
you can kind of
in any one of those holes you can look
around say like hey so what what's
available to me here like what are the
things that i can use and it'll tell you
like oh in this context you have the
following variables and here are their
types
things like that
um
oh i have a typo there um yeah and
basically with the type development
anything that is a function can be
become a type so functions can return
types so based on the value that is
passed into a function you can get
different types out of it so it's like
this weird cool thing
i hope it catches on because it's really
it feels refreshing to work in it
so maybe you'll get a chance to go on
vacation and interest at some point
maybe you'll decide to go there
right
[Music]
all right
so
talked a lot about work i'll work in no
play makes everyone dull
so i'm gonna
this is gonna be sort of now for
something completely different
um i run these events in the san
francisco office
uh i've now run five of them uh and i
call them open studios and the reason i
do that is explicitly and they're called
jupiter open studios is explicitly to
call out to this idea that we don't
always have to be doing purposeful
things
right so somebody might complain to me
and say idris is so academic i could
never get a job doing it that's not the
point right
like you can't get a job in the
galapagos
that doesn't mean you shouldn't go there
right to change the way that you think
about the world and so with these open
studio events i sort of distinguish them
from hackathons as we're not trying to
accomplish anything we're just trying to
bring community together of local
jupiter developers and anyone is welcome
like i said we run them about
four times a year
um and so i just want to show some
photos of what an open studio looks like
and and talk a little bit about it so
this is an empty room we also have a big
screen in our office this one is bigger
and more impressive um
but uh an event starts off as empty
right
and again back to programming languages
of places
what matters are the people that show up
not so much what the place looks
like okay and then i do this um oh the
color shows up there that's great i do
this ice breaker activity um i'm gonna
try to do it all the time i've missed a
few times where you tell me
three things or you write them down on
sticky so you can share with other
people
one thing that you want to learn
so this is an event that takes place in
our office over two days so people can
come either on a friday or on a saturday
or both days because not everyone can
take time off from work to just
learn and improve themselves and on the
other hand not everyone can take time
away from family
instead of um
doing more work and sort of professional
development so one thing that you want
to learn
oh excuse me
uh one thing that you want to share with
others while you're there
and then one thing that you want to try
while you're there
okay
and then that allows people to talk you
might recognize carol willing who was
here two years ago as a keynote speaker
people
end up
working part of the time a part of the
time they're just sharing their ideas
and sharing their workflows right so i
like to think of an open studio as an
extended hallway track
it's
when you go to a conference yes the
talks are important i'm very thankful
that you're all here but right after
this is a perfect continuation of the
conference and
um in the hallway you get to learn a lot
more right and so i wanted to make a
whole event that is just about the
hallway track that's what open studios
are
i'm going to sort of speed through this
as we're running out of time but you
kind of get the feeling of it by the way
on the left here that's my dad
my dad is still a software developer
and now just in the last year uh or
maybe two years he started working for
nvidia and he is now learning python and
he has been telling me he's been calling
me for help
uh when he has a syntax error or when he
has a particular thing it's fantastic
it's a great way to turn the tables
right here's the person that will used
to teach me about c plus plus i'm now
helping him
learn python or figure things out and do
his workflow
okay
coffee is go back it's like coffee is
very important right so i'm very glad we
have both coffee and tea here we have
both coffee and tea in the office as
well and people are working that was
carol again
there's white boards there's
private conferences it's a good time
your friends are willing to make silly
faces and do little fun things
um
feeding them is important there's food
as well
we do have a session for lightning talks
um and so
this was um
this was a couple of cal poly interns
that uh they're still in college they
were working with the project jupiter
over the summer and here they're showing
off this rich text editor for uh wysiwyg
markdown editing so on the right you can
see you can just click bold and italics
and underline for again non-technical
users so they were showing that off in
the most recent event
and uh yeah
more of that
and then my friends indulge me and
doing silly photos with me so that's
always fun
and in the end
they all leave right
and it's again this is back to it's the
people that matter the event is an event
that's great but it's the people that
were there that matter
all right i just have a few uh more
minutes this is similar in spirit again
in the hallway track i found out
yesterday to a local event this
hackathon that gov zero puts on
and i'm very impressed that you've had
37 events since 2012
and uh you keep doing them and keep
happening it's fantastic that's great i
was also very grateful for all the
english that was written in in the
slides in the talks that weren't in
english because i was able to follow
them so i thought i'd return the favor
and uh
not just have exclusively english lives
for you
okay
so we have 30 seconds left and a quest
appears
so there's something wrong so this is a
screenshot from the website from the gov
zero hackathon website there's something
wrong with it
but it's a little bit blurry you're
probably having a hard time
seeing it so what if we say
you know zoom in
and enhance
i can't believe that worked it's amazing
can anyone tell me what's wrong
it's about the dates
dated to top says 2019 07 20. that's
july 20th
but down below it says 097 right
so what needs to happen your mission
should you choose to accept it is go to
that repository which is where the code
lives and change the date from because
the last event was on september 7th as
far as i can see
so any one of you that's never made a
pull request before
i encourage you to go do that go do that
right now go open up github and and do
that
okay
i'm just gonna three more slides and
i'll wrap up
um
a friend of mine stephan van der waal
sent me an email set nine days ago
saying i love the the premise of your
python taiwan talk when where can i see
it as though i had already delivered it
i was like
i should have asked stefan where did you
are you do you just follow like how did
you know about this but anyway i didn't
ask that but i did ask what do you mean
what would you like me to talk about
what is it that you're getting out of my
abstract which is i gathered what what
he was talking about and so
stefan being the great friend that he is
wrote me a very long amount
and
i'll just let you read that on your own
for a few seconds but it was fantastic
that
he got the spirit of what i'm trying to
talk about
with thinking about programming places
programming languages as places which is
that we can visit other cultures we can
get the benefit of them we can import
them into our world we can export our
good ideas into
the up-and-coming programming languages
and help shape them help them not make
the mistakes that our languages sort of
went through and the pain points and
things like that
so that's just great
um that's a picture of my whole family
that's my dad up at the top again i'm on
the very right
and uh
the great thing about programming
thinking about programming languages as
places is that
unlike real physical places it doesn't
cost us anything
in terms of time or money really to
switch and to go somewhere else right
it took me a while to get here
from california but if i want to go to
golang i could just
open up my laptop right after this talk
and switch right
another amazing thing and this is why i
have the photo up here is again unlike
the physical world you can also go back
in time it's a time machine you don't
have to you don't get to just travel
in terms of physical places you get the
time travel because you can still go
back and use c plus 11 or you can still
go back and use python26 if you liked it
so much
it's amazing right the technology allows
us to do that it's great
so with that i want to thank you for
your time and attention
here are some resources related to this
and i'll put the slides up so that you
can
you can take advantage of those there
are some similar ideas that were covered
stacy morse was instrumental in helping
me
define open studios when i came up with
a concept
and she has a great python talk about
using art critique principles for code
reviews so that's fantastic uh livable
code by sarah may is a similar idea
zoomed in if you think about your code
base as a living room or as a house that
you share with a bunch of people you're
going to act a certain different way
you're not going to leave a mess for
somebody else to clean up because you
drop the glass of milk by the fridge
right you're going to clean that up
and so
there's some others and as promised
here's my contact information thank you
so much